las reacciones cn 1 y sn 2 involucran a
los grupos salientes entonces veamos
esta tabla de pecados para estudiar
mejor esos grupos del lado izquierdo
tenemos a los ácidos y por ejemplo el
ácido clorhídrico h y tiene un pecado de
aproximadamente menos 11 recuerden entre
menor sea el valor de pecado más fuerte
es el ácido entonces en esta tabla el
valor de pecar de menos 11 nos dice que
el ácido cítrico es el ácido más fuerte
y entre más fuerte sea el ácido más
estable es la base conjugada entonces la
base conjugada de lachay es y menos el
año en yoduro y como esta es la base con
jugada del ácido más fuerte esta es la
base más estable vamos a escribirlo
es la base más estable de la tabla lo
que significa que el año en yoduro es un
excelente grupo saliente porque es muy
estable después tenemos el ácido brom
hídrico con un pk de aproximadamente
menos 9 y su base conjugada es el año en
bromuro así que también es una base
conjugada muy estable y por lo tanto es
un buen grupo saliente y para el hc l su
base conjugada s la neón cloruro que
también es un buen grupo saliente
entonces aquí pueden ver todos estos
años es saludo o también llamados
halogenuros que son los grupos salientes
de los mecanismos en química orgánica lo
escribiré todos estos son ejemplos de
buenos grupos salientes buenos grupos
salientes y ahora veamos este ácido que
tenemos de lado izquierdo
este es el ácido p tolueno sulfónico que
tiene un pecado de menos 3 sigue siendo
ácido
y esta es su base conjugado a este año
se le conoce como grupo tos y la pto
vamos a escribir este es el grupo 2 y la
tos y como es un grupo voluminoso en
lugar de siempre dibujar todo esto lo
pueden encontrar escrito como o ts y si
quieren le podemos poner una carga
formal negativa en el oxígeno
entonces en muchas reacciones se
encontrarán el grupo tos y la tos como
grupo saliente veamos un ejemplo de otro
ácido aquí tenemos al h 3 o más el
johnny drone ya que tiene un pk de menos
2 y la base con jugada del h 3 o más es
h 2
así que el agua también es un buen grupo
saliente ok regresemos hasta arriba
miren todos los ácidos de los que hemos
hablado tienen valores de pk negativos
menos 11 menos 9 menos 7 menos 3 y menos
2 y observen que todas las bases con
jugadas son buenos grupos
así que podemos decir que si un nacido
tiene un valor de pk negativo la base
conjugada será un buen grupo saliente
veamos otro ejemplo de un nacido ahora
tenemos agua el pk del agua es 15.7
positivo así que no es un ácido muy
fuerte y su base conjugada es el año en
hidróxido o h - pero es un mal grupo
saliente el ión hidróxido es un mal
grupo saliente porque el agua no es un
ácido fuerte observen este valor de pk a
+ 15.7 y si ahora analizamos el etanol
es la misma situación el etanol tiene un
pecado de 16 positivo por lo que el año
net óxido no es un buen grupo saliente
así que como estos valores de pecas son
positivos estas bases conjugadas no son
muy estables eso significa que son malos
grupos salientes vamos a escribirlo
estos son ejemplos de malos grupos
salientes mal los grupos salientes
las reacciones c n 1 y s n 2 necesitan
buenos grupos salientes sin embargo la
reacción sn 1 es un poco más sensible
entonces veamos el cloruro de termo tilo
supongamos que reacciona mediante el
mecanismo sn 1 así que el primer paso es
la pérdida del grupo saliente estos
electrones se van junto con el cloro y
formamos el a neón cloruro que tiene una
carga formal negativa y acabamos de ver
en la tabla de pecas que el a nyon
cloruro es una base con jugada estable
por lo tanto este es un buen grupo
saliente y bueno como le quitamos un
enlace al carbono de color rojo
ahora el carbono rojo tiene una carga
formal positiva formamos un kart
vocación terciario y como este es el
paso determinante de nuestro mecanismo
sn uno la formación de un buen grupo
saliente ayuda a que el mecanismo s en
eeuu no pueda ocurrir ahora
veamos este alcohol si hacemos lo mismo
que en el ejemplo anterior decimos ok el
primer paso es la pérdida del grupo
saliente y estos electrones se van con
el oxígeno bueno pensemos qué grupo
saliente sería ése sería el guión
hidróxido que por la tabla de pecas
sabemos que no es un buen grupo saliente
entonces el a nyon hidróxido no es tan
estable como el año en cloruro entonces
el a nyon cloruro es un buen grupo
saliente y elaño en hidróxido es un mal
grupo saliente por lo tanto ese no es el
primer paso de este mecanismo
necesitamos un mejor grupo saliente y
podemos lograr eso con una fuente de
protones supongamos que tenemos una
fuente de protones tenemos un ácido en
solución entonces digamos que aquí
tenemos un h más ahora el primer paso es
protón ar el alcohol entonces nuestro
alcohol actúa como una base y toma un
protón dibujemos lo que nos queda aquí
tenemos nuestro
después tenemos el grupo metilo y ahora
el oxígeno está unido a dos hidrógenos y
aún tenemos un par de electrones libres
en el oxígeno lo que le da una carga
formal positiva entonces digamos que los
electrones de color rosa tomaron este
protón y formaron este enlace
ok ahora sí ya estamos listos para la
pérdida del grupo saliente porque si
ahora estos electrones se van con el
oxígeno formamos agua como grupo
saliente voy a dibujarlo por aquí
esta es la molécula de agua y voy a
resaltar esos electrones de color de
color azul entonces estos electrones se
van con el oxígeno y así formamos agua y
por la tabla de pecas sabemos que el
agua es un buen grupo saliente ok y como
le quitamos un enlace a este carbono de
color rojo entonces también se forma un
carbó catión terciario vamos a dibujar
este es nuestro anillo después tenemos
el grupo metilo y tenemos una carga
formal positiva en este carbono de color
rojo
entonces si conocemos los valores de pk
podremos determinar la estabilidad de la
base conjugado y por lo tanto podremos
saber si es un buen grupo saliente o no
y eso nos ayudará mucho cuando dibujemos
los mecanismos